[Musique]
on
oui
si les choses avancent comme nous
l'avons souhaité au niveau de la mine et
que nous le constations je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup d'espoir à voir donc je veux
qu'on atteint par rapidement cette
chambre de le fusiller des liquides
m
c'est là où j'ai commencé dans on parle
de l'eau comment se déroulent les
travaux nous avons de l'espoir ils ont
l'espoir est là où se trouve aujourd'hui
ce n'est plus trop besoin donc de la
chambre
espérons maintenant que
minois pas nos chauffeurs dans on ait
omis des éléments nous on y est au mieux
nous chauffer à l'air l'atout numéro est
adonné nation à la région du mékong est
à
vocation
[Musique]
il